[Music]
thank you
foreign
where we sit through philosophy to find
practical advice you can use in your
everyday life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm
joined by my co-host Dr Greg Sandler
today we're talking about
stakeholders versus stockholders and
this is a set of ideas that come out
originally in the field of business
ethics and corporate governance so this
may sound a little abstruse to some of
our listeners at first but trust me
we've got a lot of great stuff for how
this actually does apply to ordinary
life and the decision making that we're
involved taking it out of the sphere of
business you don't have to be a
executive or manager or own a company in
order to make this useful and now Dan
this is this is an idea that you propose
that we should talk about what was your
original
impetus for proposing this because it's
been a little while and I don't quite
remember
I think we were talking about the
different ways our
um systems that we've set up on benefit
who in the society and like obviously
this is you know directly related to
ethics because ethics is in part A study
about how we ought to treat each other
and so we're going to be talking about
some normative things which are things
that we want Otts to do within a system
um based on that system
um and so if you have a system that says
that you I don't know
ought to kick cats then it is normative
for you to kick cats
um we should avoid that one yeah I think
that's a bad system but yeah just
because there are systems and they are
normative doesn't mean that they are
good in it themselves and so we have a
number of systems that we already have
in place
um and we should look at them in like
every system is not good in its of
itself just because it's the current
system that we have we should go through
regular review and see if they are still
actually beneficial to us as Society
yeah and so with talking about
shareholders and stakeholders
at least in the business environment
there's there's a lot of talk at times
about stakeholders and we'll discuss
exactly what that idea is and who it
covers in just a minute but it seems
like in a lot of cases the primary
attention is still what can we do for
shareholders so we should clarify what
we mean by shareholders those who have a
stake you know because stakeholders as a
broader concept so are we just talking
about people who own a part of a company
or derive some sort of you know legally
Define benefits from from the company or
what do you what do you take yeah
yes we it is you know stakeholders
versus shareholders and yes all
shareholders are stakeholders but this
is a you know a Venn diagram where they
uh one uh circle is completely subsumed
or encapsulated within the other whereas
the uh
share us for the stakeholders or are all
those people who have a vested interest
in the activities and the decision
making of that organization usually we
talk about this in reference to
businesses but um we'll see at some
point in time that we that these things
become more actionable on on much
different types of organizations and so
some of those people that are
stakeholders are you know owners uh
obviously the one that we just talked
about but also the employees the
managers otherwise sometimes referred to
as agents within the business Community
um the customers Society uh creditors
suppliers the government and uh well
customers again but
um that those are like the some of the
the core uh stakeholders we can talk
about other stakeholders that are even
more far flung but I feel like it's
going to get a little bit far from what
we need to talk about right now to make
this distinction yeah and and that was a
concept so the the notion of
stakeholders been getting a lot of
traction say over the last 40 years or
so as a matter of fact there was even
some sort of big conference and I don't
remember what it was it was pre-coveted
and it was you know the Big Marketing
mocks of uh corporations and governments
getting together to talk about
stakeholder capitalism and the need to
be like attentive to how other people
were being affected besides those who
own uh share in a company
um and you know some of these are
probably more important you know
employees you you can't run a company
without employees so if your decision
May taking is continually trying to you
know here's a a model that they like do
more with less right I mean at a certain
point you're doing
um damage to the people that are
actually working for you or you could be
selling out your customers you could be
exploiting them and if you really treat
them as a stakeholder as somebody who
has what we call an Ethics moral
standing whose outcomes you have to care
about
uh you have to take into consideration
well you can't screw over your customers
as part of your business model
suppliers you know
um if you if you treat them badly
um yeah as some corporations do Walmart
is a great example of a corporation that
would really stick it to suppliers
because they had so much weight in the
market
that would be uh treating a stakeholder
very badly and it's interesting that you
bring up the government too because you
don't see that a lot in business ethics
textbooks but businesses pay taxes or at
least they should be and that that
should be part of you know the
conception of a stakeholder and you know
of course the taxes are supposed to be
doing things for other people who could
fit into other classes here but that
does seem to be quite important and it
seems like this came about yourself like
it started becoming kind of you know in
the last 40 years but there's been like
a ramp up of it yeah
it's become this uh like new thing that
we're talking about not because it's
particularly a new idea because it's
like right right
um but that
in the last you know 30 40 years
um our economy at least here in the
United States has become increasingly
more towards the side of a shareholder
Supremacy like you know that everything
has to be only in reference to the
shareholder and so this is resulted in a
number of really negative outcomes for a
lot of people within
um businesses in our society and so
people are like okay something's wrong
something is breaking here what is the
reasoning behind this and so a lot of
people are saying that we are not
actually building those uh businesses in
a way that are actually sustainable for
the workforce and are actually
beneficial for the community
and so you see
um
you know you know like one of the ones
that we talked about a while back was uh
casinos
you know they're always pitched as oh
this is going to be a great Boon for the
community it's going to provide a
thousand or two thousand jobs
and uh you know it'll bring tourist
dollars in and you know what the studies
show is that oftentimes over the long
run casinos wind up being a net loss not
for the the shareholders who do great
they make tons of money because The
House Always Wins but the employees
don't get good jobs out of it and it
winds up
um really affecting the local community
by bringing a lot of people in who spend
their money
imprudently and wind up having uh bad
outcomes as a result I think if I
remember right when we looked at that we
did see that the government quite often
gets its share so you could say that
stakeholder is doing just fine but the
others are not yeah
and so uh and obviously a big
um stakeholder is the people living
around them so for example you talk
about like big industry or whatnot and
if you're you know constantly polluting
the stakeholders of the the society that
lives directly around one of your
facilities their quality of life might
be going down on they're not paying
further this is usually referred to as a
negative externality but the people that
live right next to your factory are very
much affected by your decisions within
your company yeah those are your
stakeholders and depending on what kind
of pollution we're talking about you
know prime example of this from in the
past was up in the Fox Valley there were
a lot of paper mills and
um you know now they're they're more
environmentally friendly but in the 50s
they sure as hell weren't and so by the
time the Fox River actually got down by
Waukesha uh if you were to swim in it
you were really taking your life in your
hands it was so polluted that people
would get burned you know from all these
these things that were in it
um they didn't get paper cuts
yeah if the water got thick enough right
sorry you know and they've done some
some jobs and and cleaning it up and and
removing that but you know you could
have a pollutant that is hundreds of
miles away
um and a lot of times they didn't even
really think about it when they started
doing that you know so now you mentioned
expanded ideas of stakeholders and we do
talk about this in business ethics
classes which by the way I'm going to be
teaching again this semester
um I got called in kind of last minute
to take on another section of business
ethics at Marquette and this is actually
something that we begin with in week one
um so who who else could be a
stakeholder who could be affected by the
decisions you're making so you know
you've got the local community so you
know we're here in Milwaukee if we do
something
that negatively affects or positively
affects the local community that's
that's good or bad but but we could also
be affecting people all over all over
the place you know the larger Global
community and then you know another
thing and I think there's a fascinating
one to consider future Generations we
often don't think very far ahead or if
we do we do it in very abstract terms
like oh we're going to create jobs well
okay how long are those jobs going to be
around are they the sort of thing where
the current crop of employees could
actually potentially retire from those
jobs and their kids could step in you
know or are you just talking about a job
that has at most a five-year Horizon and
then some people and I I'd be curious to
see what you think about this idea Dan
because I'm kind of conflicted about it
um
the environment can be considered a
stakeholder that to me seems pretty
tricky to to assess right because are
you talking about like all the animals
and the plants or are you putting them
all together in one big thing that we
call like capital E environment or do we
take into account like they they have
done in some countries giving like
Rivers legal rights and and treating
them as essentially entities or not you
know uh
formations of the natural world that are
sacred to particular indigenous peoples
I don't know I I think the verdict is is
still kind of out on that one but what I
mean what do you think about that it's
like it's weird to like
think about the different ways that you
could consider why does the environment
have value or moral worth and these
things is the environment only have the
moral worth because we need it to
sustain ourselves we would destroy our
environment it's bad for us either our
enjoyment or our ability to live in it
and thus that makes it bad or is it
something that has more worth in and of
itself and not as just a means to our
own
um happiness and uh being able to live
yeah and so depending on how you answer
that question I feel like there's kind
of different answers to like how I feel
about that
um uh
well that's I mean that makes perfect
sense right making distinctions and then
saying if you mean this if you mean this
I've got different answers that's that's
what we do in philosophy all the time
right rather than say well we've got the
one blanket answer to everything you
know that's usually how we get in a lot
of trouble now sometimes the best answer
is it depends and it's okay
also and sometimes it's okay to say you
don't know and let's investigate
that's that's true yeah that now we're
getting into sort of methodology about
stuff here but
um which is taking us a little bit far
from our our original topic but um I
know it's good stuff to talk about
though yeah
um maybe for another time but
let's talk about stakeholder Theory yeah
that'll lead it lead us through what
that that actually means because I think
a lot of people hearing that they their
eyes might be glazing over already what
the hell are you what do you mean by
that and so there's only like the the
especially at least from a kind of a
high level view it's like oh yeah you
need to be aware of uh the uh decisions
and the uh
how things affect those people that are
not just the shareholders but also the
employers the managers and customers and
um Society but like you'll have
um people that are like uh followers of
like Milton Friedman that say like oh no
this is already built into the the
shareholder theory that if you're going
to maximize the shareholder that's
automatically going to make you maximize
for these other people because if you
don't have good workers then you're
going to reduce your long-term profits
if you don't
um
take care of your customers your
customers are going to leave you if
you're if you're um uh not worried about
your managers then you're going to lose
your investment all these things they
say like hey this is already dealt with
but there are some like three major
things here that
um really make uh the foundations of
stakeholders theory different than a
stockholder Theory you know since we've
mentioned uh Friedman I just want to
like say just a little bit about him and
and the piece that always gets brought
up so he had this short editorial called
the social responsibility of business is
to increase its profits and this was
written in 1970 so this is going back
quite a ways and you know a lot of the
businesses at the time were saying
things like you know we should avoid
raising our prices even though inflation
is becoming an issue because we don't
want to contribute to that problem or we
should like make sure that our employees
are really well taken care of or you
know we've got this social
responsibility to do that and Friedman
was saying no no no no no no that is a
bad idea you're in effect taxing your
customers or you know transferring these
costs to other people the so you know
the motto the social responsibility of
business is to increase its profits now
what goes into that the Assumption of
what will later be called trickle-down
economics
the idea that if you are making a
business more profitable and thereby
paying out to a select few of usually
rich people who are the shareholders
they're going to spend more money
they're gonna they're gonna invest it
they're going to like you know look out
for society so the business shouldn't be
doing that as a matter of fact that's a
bad thing from Friedman's perspective
and what you're relying on there is like
rich people to do their fair share and
the track record of that is pretty poor
you know over the last 50 years and it's
interesting to see that a lot of the
things that many people would have
considered a businesses or a owner's
social responsibility have been
you know progressively paired away so
that I think there's a lot of people now
who think I don't have any
responsibility to the world the public
my local community my employees any of
that sort of stuff I just gotta maximize
profits
and I guess I think you and I are in
agreement that that is not going to
result in the best outcomes
not even close to the best I think we
can say you know I mean because we don't
want to say ah let's get rid of
capitalism altogether that that's not
feasible right now
um but we certainly don't want you know
the kind of Monopoly capitalism or as we
often call it crony or corrupt
capitalism that takes place and you know
we're we're for example and I realize
we're getting a little in the weed so we
got to come back to stakeholder Theory I
think that there's businesses out there
in the present for example in health
care or the insurance uh industry where
their business model is predicated on
making it as difficult as possible for
people to actually access the care that
they've paid for
and that provides them with
profitability
now that's that's an evil way to go
about things you know
um now is it is it a bad thing from a
shareholder perspective this is what's
wrong with the shareholder perspective
it can't say that's a bad thing to do
but if you are like deliberately
screwing over your customers and maybe
even your employees who use your your
services
um that's that's bad that's wrong you
know yeah
uh well since we're talking about this
let's we're gonna just give us a
background like so stakeholder or
stockholder theories major ones there
are our agency theories or the agency
theory where managers those people that
are working for the stockholders so this
is your
um
your
CEO or your corporate uh your c-suite
um so uh as well as all those people
that work as managers down the line but
those are your main people those are
your main agents that are working for in
your interest as a stockholder
um so managers are ethically obliged to
advance the financial interests of
corporate shareholders in preference to
the interests of other stakeholders that
is that managers have an exclusive
fiduciary obligation to shareholders
yeah and I I think that's those are two
key things right so a manager doesn't
have to say I'm deliberately going to
screw everybody except for the the
shareholders right they could even be
beneficial in some ways to
um various uh stockholders stakeholders
like you know I'm gonna do some things
for the employees but the employees will
always come last compared to the to the
stockholders you know or the customer
will always come last in comparison to
them right and so this
this does not
make it so that you're always screwing
over everyone but it does allow you to
screw over anyone as long as it's going
to be in a pursuit of a larger bottom
line
yeah
uh
so if you can get away with it it's cool
kind of is the idea here are I think you
can say too that if you're not
if you're not considering stakeholders
um in general as being
not necessarily as important as the
stockholders but pretty close
whatever model you have is probably not
going to be sustainable over time
right because things wind up being very
let's we'll call we'll call it
extractive you know
um whereas if you want to have a company
that's going to be around for
Generations you have to have a Workforce
that actually wants to be there and
continue working for you you have to
have customers who feel like you're not
the only game in town and they're
grudgingly going along with you because
as soon as there's an innovation they're
going to leave you for for that other
new company so if you if you know you're
like business history this is you know
kind of the difference between before
and after Jack Welch at GE
before you had she was the largest
company and in the United States if not
the world
um and it provided you know
tens of thousands of you know a family
uh supporting jobs you had people that
would spend their entire lives working
for GE
um have a good pension be able to you
know live a good life working on for a
company that saw them as you know
Partners in producing this wealth and
then after Jack well Welch it turns into
a very extractive
um uh model that was for a shareholder
premise here you know that the exclusive
um fiduciary's responsibility to
shareholders at the expense of everyone
else including things like
um stack ranking for the employees where
basically they said every manager every
year has to rank
um all the employees under them and
buyer the bottom 10 which then turns
everything in that organization from a
Cooperative model to a uh yeah and and
so it not only does it
um it
potentially lower wages it reduces
morale there's lots of like really
negative results from some of these very
uh stockholder first uh priorities yeah
you know I think that another thing that
contributes to it is
um something that took off very much so
in the late 70s and has continued on
today which is uh the ability of
companies to like you know engage in
mergers and Acquisitions and buy up all
sorts of other companies you know so you
see this for example in the medical
field where in the past I don't know if
we talked about this before but it's
actually like one of my rants
um in the past a hospital was its own
kind of institution and it might have
been profitable or it might have
operated at a deficit you know
um but the whole goal of it were the
goals of medicine to alleviate pain to
alleviate suffering to promote Health to
keep people from you know dying early
all those sorts of things and those so
they could serve a bunch of different
stakeholders quite naturally doing that
and then when hospitals were able to
start
forming into groups by buying up other
hospitals and becoming essentially
companies and we had like a health care
sector of the economy and then you know
Venture Capital got into it and you
could have like people who are just
interested as stockholders in buying
their way into a medical group and then
seeing profits come out of that well
um we started seeing a lot of Corners
being cut you know under the the guise
of cutting costs and so people weren't
getting the medication that they needed
or the tests or the procedures and
doctors were not being treated all that
well nurses were often treated worse
when they become yeah merely employees
right
um and and it leads to worse outcomes
overall when you have to worry about
well if I go to this place am I actually
going to get decent care or is everybody
there burnt out and just like holding on
that's not the fault of those those
people nor even necessarily the
immediate Hospital administrators it's
it's the fault of the larger
extractive organization which lost its
original goal of healing people and
became about making money and you know
we can say similar things about
educational institutions
when they're more interested in like
building their endowment than they are
and serving the students or holding on
to their staff and faculty and treating
them well and the board is going along
with this
um essentially the border the c-suite
you know you've got the the president
and Chancellor and you know upper level
VPS but you know the board is are the
people who actually get to sign off on
on the big decisions
um you know education ceases to be the
central Telos or purpose or goal and it
becomes about you know Prestige you're
making money or whatever whatever else
it it's going to be
one thing that you said it was like
really Central to this whole idea of
stakehold versus stockholder and he said
to turn nurses into merely employees and
the fact that you just said yearly
employees says a lot about the value of
our system that sees employees as
um of little value and interchangeable
too yeah yeah
um and so
that is from a you know a shareholder
position perspective totally fine you
know it's like you drop dead tomorrow
they're gonna go find someone else to
fill your place
um they don't care yeah for the most
part
um whereas a stakeholder uh idea of how
things are made the these no longer a
merely employee is uh nothing to scoff
at the employees now a a partner and not
something to
um have to just manage a mere employee
you could say becomes a contradiction in
terms right because if they are an
employee and you actually do take
employee outcomes and morale and that
sort of thing seriously then the the
mirror can't be applying to them right
is a category error
yeah
um yeah that's interesting so I guess
coming back to so now we've talked about
like uh you know agency theory about
like this you know stakeholders start
stockholder Supremacy it's a little bit
hard to make sure that I'm saying one is
not the other yeah
um but uh in stakeholder theory in
contrast to that
um there are
um
three major like uh principles of this
and the first one is that the managers
or the agents
um do not have an exclusive fiduciary
obligation to shareholders so this is
the opposite of what we just said
um and
um the is to distribute the fruits of
the organizational success and potential
failure among all legitimate uh
stakeholders and so actually I want to
add one thing and they're the reason why
the the
idea of the uh shareholder uh agency
model is was so prevalent is this a
supremacy of private property and that's
the if you are putting money into a
thing you are the the last one to get
paid out like here all your employer
employees you you have a contract with
and you pay them a flat rate whatever
their contract is but then any profits
that accrue to the same automatically go
to the stake or the shareholders and so
that's this this reason why they have
these uh values set in place because
they're the ones that have like the skin
in the game and to totally dismiss the
you know
the workers their time their energy
their mental health their physical
health depending on the job
um are not having skin in the game it
seems uh just a mismatch of reality
because we're just looking at things
from a very a narrow point of view yeah
that's that's quite interesting because
employees very often even in
Dysfunctional organizations will exhibit
a sense of let's call it pride or
partial ownership over what's happening
or sometimes when things go bad with a
company they will feel guilt or
responsibility for how decisions that
they didn't have any part in that were
made at a much higher level effect say
the customer you know I I remember
riding on a Greyhound bus down to
Chicago and there I would transfer to
get down to my graduate school in in
Carbondale in Illinois and I was sitting
next to an older guy and he was a
Tradesman he'd worked on a lot of
concrete stuff and I think he was near
retirement or maybe already retired and
as we're passing going from Milwaukee
down to Chicago he would point out a
building and he'd say that's my building
and I'd be like what you own it and he's
like no I worked on it I helped build
that building now he understood of
course that he didn't like build the
whole the whole building he did some
parts in it but he felt like
you know invested like it was it was uh
he'd given some of himself and that gave
him the right to say this is this is
mine
and I think that's often lacking to a
lot of employees nowadays where you know
nobody cares about what happens to to
them and
um how you know and at the same time
oftentimes the bosses are expecting them
we're all one big happy family here you
should actually care about this you know
and probably the the most egregious case
that's been you know it's it's a long
time ago now at this point
um I want to say almost 20 years is
Enron but we still teach it in business
classes in part because Enron actually
had an award-winning 70 page
code of ethics which of course they
didn't follow because they allowed
um exceptions to it and then they made
exceptions about everything but the
saddest part of Enron
was that the employees had been
encouraged to buy Enron stock
um you know to invest in the company
right so it was a way of sort of like
pretending to treat them as uh
stakeholders by actually treating them
as minor shareholders when the
executives knew that they were cooking
the books and that sooner or later
everything was gonna collapse and so
many employees why it was just popping
the stock up anyways exactly and a lot
of them lost their entire life savings
everything that they had they'd invested
in this this company because they
thought it was legit and when it went
Belly Up it really ruined a lot of
people's lives in the South and it's
[Music]
between like you know
the sex versus the the actual actions
um of an organization like you can say
we're all happy family and that we're
all here to support each other but if
your your actual actions and the uh the
fruits of the labor of the organization
do not match these speech acts and
you're going to have a problem people
are not going to believe you uh
you
if you're actually going to give some of
the profits back to the to the people
um to treat them with the respect and
dignity that you know at least a human
requires yeah
then you saying these things is just
making everyone think that you're a liar
um because a lot of times you are and
you're just trying to extract
value out of that labor without actually
giving the the due pay for that labor
that has been required
that's right yeah and you're depriving
people
uh when you're engaging in deception
this is something that Norman Bowie who
is a business ethicist associated with
what's often called conscient capitalism
um he points out that when deception is
taking place by the part on the part of
management or what you know the
executives in relation to the employees
you are treating somebody as a mirror
means to whatever end that you want
you're not treating them with with human
dignity and it's interesting because you
think about a manual con's ethical
Theory it's very abstract seems very
rigorous and hard to apply but Bowie I
think very successfully shows how it
would be applied within the day-to-day
context of of ordinary businesses you
know that that formulation of the
categorical imperative is one that I
I use as a crutch like whenever I'm like
looking at a new ethical dilemma I was
like okay
whose ends am I working for here yeah uh
so uh the second principle that is
different from our our previous uh
stakeholder agency theory
is or sorry stockholder agency theory is
that stakeholders should have input in
the decision-making process of the
organization this gives them one buy-in
and there are moral obligations to each
of these stakeholders if you don't have
the the input that uh
you know is going to be a a bad uh bad
outcome for one of these stakeholders
um then you you it's easy to make a
decision without any pushback so for
example in Germany
um every company has on their board at
least one member that represents the
actual workers and so at the highest
level of decision making within the the
company there is at least one if not
more people at the table with voting
rights that are there representing the
uh where with all the the the values the
the needs of the employees yeah that's a
great example I can think of another
interesting example with a distinction
so imagine that
um you've got a whole bunch of employees
and there's customers and you are
involved in management now one thing you
could say to the employees you gather
them all together in a room and you're
like customers are the absolute backbone
of our cash flow without them there's no
Acme company right so you would better
treat those customers well the customer
is always right right I don't care what
it takes you go the extra mile to make
sure the customers are are happy now it
looks like you're acknowledging a
stakeholder group right the customers
and maybe there's something legitimate
to that right now some customers are bad
customers of course so you don't want to
be quite so sweeping but what you're
doing is you're taking your employees
and you're treating them as if they're
mere cogs in a machine there to treat
the customers right or you could say
similar things for the suppliers you
know you would better you employees a
better uh treat the the suppliers as if
they are the best people on Earth and if
you don't we're gonna punish you well
then again you're acknowledging one set
of uh stakeholders and ignoring another
one what would be more important not
even ignoring but like going to give
negative consequences to to be emerged
yes yeah exploiting right dominating so
with the buy-in you know you can explain
to employees who aren't totally burnt
out already and now you know about
a lot of employees are because they've
been mistreated right so it's like
people who have been in bad
relationships but let's say you've got
some pretty fresh employees they're
willing to listen and you're like why do
we actually care about these customers
why do we actually care about the local
community let's think this through and
you invite them into a conversation and
you actually listen to them when they're
like well what about the customers who
are jerks to us you know and you're like
oh that's a good question let's actually
think about why they still kind of
matter but you can lay down certain
limits you can go find a manager who
will deal with the BS that these people
are bringing to the table well that's a
totally different situation right now
you're treating employees as if they do
matter as other people and you're
treating them as as legitimate
stakeholders rather than just as
somebody else who's going to be
sacrificed to these stakeholders
and so the the final of the these
principles is this idea between
normative stakeholders and derivative
stakeholders and so it's kind of like
trying to take we know that we have a
larger set of stakeholders than just
shareholders
um but there are there's definitely like
a first tier and then kind of a second
here and the first tier they
kind of agree on our financers the
employees the customers the suppliers
and the local communities yeah and so
these are the people in which these two
first things have to be applied to so
this is once again the uh the agents or
the managers uh have in a fiduciary
obligation to these normative
stakeholders and the
um stakeholders these normative
stakeholders should have input in the
decision-making process of the
organization or put it another way from
um
uh he says that a managers of an
organization do not have an exclusive
fiduciary duty to any one stakeholder
group but rather or obligated to ensure
that the value created by the
organization is distributed among all
normative stakeholders and that a
normative stakeholder have input into
the managerial decisions that determine
how the organization attempts creates
attempts to create that value normative
stakeholders include the organization's
finances employers customers suppliers
and local community
uh yeah and and now you can think well
man I wouldn't want to be a manager
there I got to listen to too many people
but I don't think it's actually that
difficult to if you are a good to be a
good manager involves being a good
communicator you know not just like
ordering people around but you know
producing like you said buy-in and
consensus
yeah and it
if you're only getting one voice and
you're only going to get a very small
amount of the the actual full picture
it's kind of like uh you know a lot of
Point yeah yeah on images uh like on
your TV are gonna be made up of a red
green and blue
um little LEDs or a little you know um
pixels of some sort and if you if only
the red ones are slighting up you're
going to get a much different picture
than you are going to get of if the rest
of them show up and so the Fuller
picture gives you better information
which if you're getting better
information you're probably going to get
better
um
uh information that gives you better
ability to make better decisions that
are going to actually be uh better for
the long term uh viability of the
organization as well as uh profits
within that organization if that is the
uh point of the organization
that's right yeah
I mean there's so many companies that
have screwed themselves over by allowing
managers and Executives to essentially
dictate what's going to happen without
ever listening to employees or customers
even you know suppliers play an
important role in that if if your
supplier says listen we just can't keep
up with the the pace as you're scaling
up and provide quality and you don't
listen to them boy you're going to run
into a lot of problems you know yeah
um and so I guess there's also a couple
of um sub theories within stakeholder
Theory and so these we just went through
the principles but then
um there's a a subset that kind of tries
to
um be descriptive on this descriptive
empirical uh sub Theory which tries to
describe and explain how current
corporate behaviors actually work in a
different
um uh setups of how they they are are
run and so what happens when you have a
purely State uh shareholder on LED
organization versus maybe a shareholder
a stakeholder one or maybe uh some quite
different one maybe maybe you have a
organization that is um completely run
by the employees
um at the detriment to other people
within the organization how does that
change uh governments and outcomes
um and then there's also and that's
going to finish these off really quick
and then so instrumental is used to
identify the connections or lack the
connections between stakeholder
management and the achievements of
traditional corporate objectives usually
you know profitability and growth and
then there's normative
which is used to interpret the function
of the corporation including the
identification of moral or philosophical
guidelines for the operation and the
management of those corporations
[Music]
yeah I was going to say with the
descriptive very often what we're doing
there what we call case studies you know
where we set out the information and
then we like start to analyze it and say
well did this actually work did this
work who got left out who who got
perhaps more than their fair share you
know I mean it's difficult to have a
purely descriptive approach anymore I
mean and it's very difficult to have a
purely normative approach either but
yeah
you know um since you brought up moral
theories I I thought you know there's
there's a number that are kind of the
big Heavy Hitters when we're doing
applied ethics and
um typically we talk about five but I'll
just bring up four here we talk about
utilitarianism which we've discussed
before and you can express that pretty
simply by saying that what you're trying
to do is uh maximize positive outcomes
and minimize negative outcomes for
everybody concerned and and balance
those out and that's a very common
approach in business ethics
we also talk about deontological ethics
where we're looking at you know rights
or rules or duties and we're saying
there are certain lines that you can't
cross and so we mentioned Emmanuel Kant
he's a great example of a deontological
thinker and then we have virtue ethics
where we're more concerned with the
motivation and character of the people
who are making the decisions and about
what we're doing to other people's
characters you know so if we're
impoverishing people we may be
generating situations where it's more
difficult for them to do that and we can
talk about corporate character or
corporate culture as well and that a
more recent or recently identified thing
is what we call ethics of care which is
coming out of feminist ethics and that
also brings something to the table and
every one of these can
inform how we look at stakeholders I
think utilitarianism super super
straightforward right
everybody's outcomes count and so
stakeholder Theory from the very
beginning is going to naturally
harmonize quite well with utilitarianism
in its in its classic forms
um and I think that the ontological
ethics
really provides a nice supplement
because you could think of it as like a
guard rail so you know you've got like
your utilitarian cost benefit analysis
let's try to make things work out the
best but you know maybe we could do that
by enslaving somebody or you know
humiliating somebody or throwing
somebody down a well you know or
torturing kittens or stuff like that and
deontology will come and say no no no
you cannot do that you know you have to
respect human dignity or you have to uh
allow people to have autonomy or you
can't use people just merely as means to
an end or you have a duty to to people
so I think those two they don't have to
be like opposed to each other they're
often really effective when we pair them
and then virtue ethics adds another
really important Dimension we think
about who we are as people and are we
genuinely good people or bad people or
somewhere in between and what do we have
to do in order to build a consistent
character that will take stakeholders
into consideration right what is what
does it mean to be somebody like a beer
manager who actually cares about their
employees you know and then this leads
us to ethics of care
that is really good for focusing on the
people who might be otherwise falling
through the cracks or marginalized or
viewed as not that important and saying
we need to have concern for them we need
to empathize with them and treat you
know treat situations a bit more
particularly and I think these moral
theories they don't have to be it's not
like you have to pick one and then you
only go with that one that's where a lot
of people go wrong in ethics they're
like I'm a utilitarian I only I only
care about that right you want to put
all of these together in kind of like a
toolbox I would say well you got to be a
little bit careful about because more
tools you have the more outs you can
potentially give yourself
it's like I can use the the worst
portions of this tool yeah yeah but that
that is going far afield from what are
the topic we're getting at
um but I wanted to yeah yes and you on
like the utility like even the
utilitarians
um had uh deontological ideas based on
the idea that like okay how do you
actually put utilitarianism into action
you have like a group of people that try
to figure out what the the uh what
actions had the most utility and then
say like hey and these things you do
these and that just you know for the the
rest of us who weren't sitting around
trying to figure out what maximizes uh
well-being or happiness there
um it's like oh well
they already figure this out you do this
in this situation that's very
deontological yeah
um
you know as a little bit of trivia the
very first use of the word deontology as
far as I know is actually by Jeremy
Bentham the father of utilitarianism he
wrote a book called deontology because
it means like the study of our duties
right
um and in it I think he basically from
what I remember it's been over 10 years
since I've read it he basically took his
earlier writings and just kind of
reformulated them so it's it's
utilitarianism called deontology
interesting so um yeah and and when we
talk about ethics here like the the
whole reason why stakeholder Theory uh
one of the main reasons we talk about it
in these ethical terms is because there
is this thing called the separation
fallacy which is the full the fallacious
belief that business and ethics are
separate Realms that's like the whole
idea of like oh this is just business no
you can never you know strip out ethics
from business you can be a businessman
and you're still an a-hole that's
but it doesn't make you not an a-hole
for just doing things that were business
you know I've been thinking about
um
a different kind of fallacy that this
would fit into that I've observed when
people get called on a particular thing
so this would apply really well to
business people who are unscrupulous and
do unethical things and then have the
excuse well I'm just maximizing
shareholder value you know
so when you point out to somebody that
they're being a jerk in a certain way
they're doing something wrong they will
oftentimes say oh I'm not doing X I'm
doing why and you'll you know if you
actually look at the the thing closely
um you're like well you are still doing
X
because y leads to X you know and uh
it's explaining how you wound up doing X
and and you are also doing why but
you're doing both of them at the same
time so I'm I'm just maximizing
shareholder value yes by robbing the
employees of their pension fund or
whatever it happens to be you're still
robbing them of their pension fund right
and the fact that you call it maximizing
shareholder value or making prudent
decision or cutting costs doesn't mean
that you're not doing this other thing
over here and people try this sort of
thing all the time they do it in
interpersonal conflict where they're
like oh I'm not attacking you I'm just
defending myself right and you're like
well you're defending Yourself by
attacking me so yeah yeah it's a like
there's moral gymnastics like how how
can I oh
our new
um standard and if you agree with this
standard
um that I'm fine but we're not talking
about that standard you're if you're
talking about like our relationship
that's this wholly different standard
and you've now you know transgressed
that but
um
now we talk to the point where how do
you actually apply this in your life and
especially if you're not like
um working in a large corporation or
something or or already in place of
Power Within These Things how do you
actually utilize this information so
um when we're talking about stakeholder
Theory and this does not only apply only
to businesses it belies to uh
organizations
um that are voluntary associations that
have three characteristics their form to
realize specific aims and purposes two
that they allow members to freely exit
and really eject other members from the
association and three the uh that
attract and retain as well as recruit
and evaluate members on the basis of
their interest in advancing the
association's objectives so so this
could be like a gaming club for example
right people who get together on a
Saturday night to play DND or something
like that yeah
what what is the win condition of d d
it's to come back and play it the next
week
well that's you know I never I never
heard that that's a good one yeah that's
definitely
and
um but like you know all the way from
like corporations to the government to a
union to
um
oh you got a political action committee
or you've got like a homeowners
association or uh a gardening club or
whatever
yeah that's that's quite interesting so
the stakeholders won't be just one sort
of uniform thing like you know suppliers
creditors employees in each of these
cases we we would have to say Okay well
who actually are the stakeholders for
this particular group so like the D and
D Club it could be the the place that
they play at it could be you know that's
providing them with a spot
um you know like a gaming place the
players themselves maybe the game
organizer and d d the GM but you know it
could be uh some some other person would
would be like at the level of like a
manager maybe
um and then you'd also have to think
about like well who are the other
stakeholders the families of these
people like if they're nerding out 24
hours a day maybe that's negatively
impacting their family right
um so for example I go and I play D D at
my friend's house but they've got two
young kids and so we have to make sure
that we are relatively quiet because we
play after they go to bed yeah to not
like no they are stakeholders in this
thing even though they're like two you
know
so it's just you know even even like
pets like dogs that need to be walked at
a certain time could be stakeholders in
that so like if you're sitting at the
table and the dogs over in the corner
whining and you're not attending to its
needs you're not meeting the obligation
to one of your important stakeholders
on Friday nights
okay now we have stakeholders that are
your neighbors and are you going to be
annoying your neighbors
yeah but having a party and having
guests fits into this this criteria who
doesn't apply it's an organization that
has a goal to have a party
I think this this could actually work if
so I wouldn't this group wouldn't
necessarily fit all those criteria that
you laid out but I think it could apply
to families
you know you can voluntarily leave a
family but thing that's a higher exit
cost yeah that's hard that's yeah
but I think it is really important in
families to figure out who the
stakeholders are and they could be like
your neighbors or they could be
um people who you pay to do things you
know so I I think this is a very an idea
a very wide application and the general
idea just to like bring it to a close
because we're going to run out of time
pretty soon is you got to take
everybody's outcomes into account if you
want to adopt a stakeholder point point
of view
and obviously it's going to take a
little bit more work like it's great
yeah you know to be the boss and and to
like you know rain down dictates from uh
like heaven but like you know if you
actually want people to
freely be there like this is one of the
things it's an organization that people
can really enter and exit and if no one
wants to follow whatever you're saying
from high they're just gonna leave
um yeah uh and it's something that you
also have to continually like retune you
know you can't fix it once and for all
and then oh I've addressed every
stakeholder because there may be some
new ones showing up or you know the
environment's going to change in some
way and it's going to change what people
are are wanting or there's new uh
pressures coming on them from whatever
so yeah you if you're not in these
regular conversations with all the
stakeholders then you're not going to be
able to meet their needs and they're
going to leave your organization
that is a great Point well do you want
to take us out on a final thought I
think we're getting close to the yeah we
leave you today with the words of Robert
Reich in the 1980s corporate Raiders
began mounting unfriendly takeovers of
companies that could deliver higher
returns to their shareholders
but only if they abandon their old
stakeholders
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]